[Music]
and let's go to scott in columbus ohio
hey what's up scott
oh not too much how you doing today sir
not too much either man y'all doing well
yeah all right you know this is my lunch
time so you know um always a work kind
of a working lunch well thanks for uh
hanging out with me during your lunch
hour so what's up man how can i help oh
well um
reasonable calling and never thought i'd
be doing something like this in my life
or anything like that so i'm more
nervous about that than talking hey
there's three or four listeners that
makes two of us man i sure never thought
i'd be doing this so we're on the same
team oh
so
you know um
my wife and i have been married for
about 10 years okay a little over 10
years now
and you know we knew going in that we
were kind of very opposite people um
she had a different she had a lot of
stuff going growing up
um you know her dad was alcohol leg she
had you know verbal abuse her mom passed
when she was 12.
and she she struggled with that stuff
early on in her adult life and
but she kind of got that under control
and
and for me i you know i get a
pretty good upbringing um
and didn't have any of that type of
stuff but i kind of wandered around
myself in my early 20s kicked around all
that stuff
went into the
navy at age 27 all those 18 year olds
thought i was really old
and i know
so i felt like i've had a couple
different lives
as as uh as the book goes on very cool
and you know in my 40s we met it was my
first marriage it was her third marriage
uh we got married and you know we we
work pretty well together and that type
of stuff but
the last few years hasn't been quite the
same and i don't know if it's just you
know our differences kind of
came to a head or we just grew apart a
little bit but
um just i'm gonna i wrote a few things
down and that's what i do when i get
ready for
an appointment or something like that
good for you um you know we haven't uh
like i said we were raised very
differently i'm just going to read down
this um
we we haven't been intimated in probably
five or six years we kind of stopped
holding hands three or four years ago
um
by intimate you haven't had sex in four
or five years five or six years
yes okay yes all right um we have we you
know we did a little kiss in the morning
um but we haven't done that in about a
year
um and just sort of settled into it
seems more like a partnership roommates
than we are
a married couple um and you know pardon
me i'm 55 so it's kind of like
okay well together we do okay
monetarily wise we we can do stuff and
you know some things we do real well
together
but uh the last few years has been kind
of a challenge because she's
kind of on the opposite uh
political side of it but it's
more than that if it was just that i
mean
if that was a big big thing we would
never have gotten together in the first
place um because i've always kind of
been more in between and
uh you know open mind and i think that's
the best way to go with that type of
stuff but you know i hear you talk a lot
about people diving into the phones
being on the internet and that's to me
that's kind of what she's done it seems
like
every
i don't know if you call them conspiracy
theories or anything like that
um she considers it seems like
everything's a fact i mean just
see if i can read
she spends all all the evening she goes
into the room probably around seven
o'clock and just
listens to her phone and stuff like that
you know she says the president is not
really president the former president's
really the president now the current
president's never been to the white
house
there's a cabal
controlling everything for the last 20
years
silver is going to go up four four
thousand percent
continue i'm taking notes
i agree with everything continue
okay all right
and she started she started buying
bitcoin and with the
the silver um you know i don't i didn't
mind it at the beginning because it's
not the worst investment it's not the
best investment and no it's the worst
it's the worst yeah it's a terrible
investment terrible and and uh you know
100 100 ounces 200 ounces okay
we could absorb that in this lesson
sat last saturday
and this is actually after i contacted
your show um she told me she finally
started to dive into bitcoin like
as as as it's collapsing in front of our
very own yeah yeah so so then i asked
her and i try to pay attention to a
point but at the same time
you know she's always she she's been
kind of more the bill payer and she does
make sure you know we have money in the
bank and all that type of stuff we're
paying bills we can go do this and that
that type of stuff we have no debt uh no
car debt no house debt or anything like
that um so we're doing okay on that but
then i asked her that day because she
knew i was not that happy about the
bitcoins so how much have
because she told me she was going to
stop at 500 ounces and she told me she's
got about 30 000 in silver right now so
that's in the last probably six or seven
months 30 thousand dollars in silver
yeah yeah
yeah so
and
i just told her i said i don't know that
we can keep going like this i said
i i just don't know that i completely
trust her with when it comes to money
absolutely so so like bring me to a head
how can i i help it sounds like there's
a lot here well i'm trying to figure out
you know
now well i guess one thing i want to say
is all that aside say that you took that
out
um all that stuff out
part of me
it maybe is ready to move on anyway
because again you know i was telling you
we haven't had sex in five or six years
so that happened before all that so why
what let me back why'd y'all stop having
sex
i don't know
we we've never talked about it so why
for five years have you never brought up
to your wife
hey we haven't had sex in
1500 days
i you know i can't can't answer that and
um it's and i'm and i'm kind of a guy
with at work and stuff that i'm always
feeling i can usually find a solution to
things and it's hard for me or maybe
it's right in my face and i'm just
ignoring it and so i thought i'd reach
out and and i am going to
do a little bit more than this i've
already got that started set up awesome
through our eap program oh that's
awesome good i'm glad you're reaching
out to somebody all right so let me let
me jump in here
first is
i hear a
somewhat of a resignation i'm 55. we're
making good money i'm tired there you go
you're tired
and your body is checked out
another word for that over time
is depression
your body's just said i'm out
and something has
begun to stoke the fire a little bit
your body's beginning to feel not safe
because your money is going out the door
now
and so i want you to hear me very very
carefully
you
deserve a
rambunctious
chaotic
hilarious
intimate sex life at the age of 55.
okay
yeah
not i don't really know we haven't had
sex in five or six years and i just
never even never even asked never even
talked about it i just like to find
solutions on my own when i can't find
them i just kind of kind of just move on
brother you're worth more than that
she's worth more than that
right and
you know she said we've had you know a
few discussions with everything and
she's told me that
you know maybe she needs to go find
like-minded people and
uh you know
i want to say back like maybe you should
you know yeah
so so and maybe that's maybe that is the
right right there maybe but me and my
wife are radically different on
different things
and i've got friends in my life that
laughingly and lovingly and mockingly
call me their hilarious liberal friend
and i've got friends in my life who are
like oh god here comes deloney super
conservative guy
because i've got different thoughts on
different topics and we've just
bifurcated the world in some stupid this
one or that one
my wife does too and we don't match on a
lot
and so there's a few topics in our house
we have agreed to not talk about
there are some topics that um
not be just because we i i know if i go
down this road we're just i'm just doing
it to start a fight and what a dumb way
to live
and i know what her thoughts are on it
and so i love her she's my wife we're
raising a family together she's my best
friend like all these things i don't
have to agree with her on this
especially when she's clearly wrong
right
and she would be telling you the same
thing like especially when he's clearly
wrong
but that doesn't impact our desire to
be together
and here's the big difference we share
the same values we just have different
beliefs
and one of our values is we will honor
each other and one of our values is
we're going to be really curious
and another one of our values is we're
not going to pick fights just to pick
fights stupid
and so i have people in my life
some that bernie sanders would be like
that's a little bit far to the left you
should probably reign it in and i've got
other friends in my life who have slept
in my house um who've shared my home
that have eaten at my table whose kids
played with my kids
who would make trump be like that's a
little bit too far to the right let's
let's wind it back a little bit right i
love that about my life
and so having different beliefs and
different like man
what an awesome way to live so the fact
that y'all are
in different camps have different ideas
like she thinks cove is a hoax and
there's some guy in the back of his
trunk with a youtube channel he's like
for the real truth right and
fine and that what is it biden's like on
a spaceship or something whatever dude
that's fantastic
um there's a way that that happens in a
relationship and it's hilarious it's
funny
and then there's a way where that type
of going down rabbit holes one way or
going down rabbit holes the other way
or a better way to say it is she goes in
at seven o'clock during what would
normally be her intimate time
and her body screaming for connection
and that's where she finds connection as
with she's created she's curated and the
internet has helped her with its
algorithms curate
a group of like-minded people who keep
her safe because at home she's got no
one
and you've done the same thing
you're tired and quite frankly it sounds
like you're lonely and i've been there
too
okay
all of this starts with two things
number one you being really really
honest with yourself about these two
questions
what do i want
and
what do i need
and when you answer the need questions
this was a game changer in my house
i need physical touch that's something
that settles my body down for a number
of reasons
and my wife is not a physical touchy
kind of person
but she'll hold my hand
she'll put her barefoot on my bare foot
under a table
not in some pervy porny way but in a
subtly way
okay
and she will put her arm on my shoulder
while i'm scrubbing the dishes and she's
grabbing something on the dishwasher
right and i am loud as i'll get out in
the mornings i wake up just ready to go
go set the world on fire
and she needs quiet in the morning and
so i'm quiet because i love her and
respect her because i spoke my needs out
loud she spoke her needs out loud and
we've got lists of our needs right all
that to say is
you need to be clear about what you need
and then the hard part which you may
need to get a counselor you may need to
have a hard conversation with your wife
is
honey here's what i need and what are
your needs
when's the last time y'all went out and
just had breakfast together and just
said hey what are the let's what are the
state of things
i love you and i miss you have you all
ever done that
no not that we i mean we go we've gone
out to breakfast and that type of stuff
but you know we our our
talks have not been the same the last
couple years as they used to be yeah and
here's the thing we used to be
go on a trip without without ever
turning on the radio because we would
talk the whole time so don't do that
anymore okay so
what you're mentioning we're roommates
we're just
co-household managers is one of the most
common
things that's going on in the country
right now in marriages so you're not
alone covet has destroyed the intimacy
people just got to got busy getting to
work
and then they didn't have friends they
didn't have their normal routines they
didn't have the trips
um it was not as fun having sex because
i see you all day every day like the
intimacy and the i don't have anything
to build up all day so i'm just well
whatever just go to bed turned into
let's just watch netflix which turned
into let's just watch youtube which
turned into oh my gosh did you know that
biden is a space alien right and now
we're done a rabbit hole somewhere
and so
it really starts with everybody saying
hey i want to wind this back and i miss
you
i miss your body i miss your touch i
miss our intimate connection i miss our
laughter i miss our talks and i feel
like
um
that you are in fight or flight you're
not safe
that your community found online is
keeping you safe and hear her
i feel like you've just given up on our
relationship i feel like you checked out
i feel like you just go home and watch
tv and put your feet up and have dinner
and
i'm just going to my bedroom and you
don't follow me
whatever that looks like and i can see
both sides i can see her saying we
haven't had sex for five years husband
and you haven't asked me about it once
and i can also see
honey we haven't had sex for five years
because you've been dating your
um
cell phone
or you've been dating youtube for the
last five years whatever the thing is
hear me say this um
you're worth more than this she's worth
more than this your marriage is worth
more than this and i don't think your
marriage is over if you don't want it to
be but it's going to take some hard
conversations by some grown adults
i'm going to send you all three all
three questions for humans okay um what
they are it's for when people have lost
connection it's a deck of cards i made
up man they're nothing special i'm
actually pretty cool but
it's a three decks of cards
and i'm going to send them to you i'm
also going to send you my new book i
want you to read it together okay on
your past change of future i'm going to
send that to you too um because both of
y'all got some stuff going on and both
of you have gotten off of the path that
y'all were supposed to be taking
together in this book will help you get
back but these these three decks of
cards questions for humans
it's just gonna help man it's gonna be
something to reintroduce conversation
together it's gonna reintroduce intimacy
together
um the deck for for couples the deck for
folks who are like you who are married
and kind of gotten off
man
merry christmas this deck will help you
come back together if you'll allow it to
okay
i want you to use this stuff
and i want you to be ready to have hard
conversations but before you do
what do you need
and what do you want scott you're a
brave man thanks for calling i know this
is hard man i know you're tired tired
tired
i want you to tell you that you're worth
getting back up dust your knees off dust
your shoulders up get some people around
you let's get back into this thing man
you're worth more than this